[Musique]
le logement d'abord adopte une approche différente
et dit d'attendre une minute, cela n'a pas de
sens, tout le monde mérite un logement, c'est un
droit et en fait, le rétablissement des gens peut
s'améliorer une fois qu'ils ont un logement, nous
vous trouverons un logement permanent et je
ne le fais pas.  Cela ne veut pas dire que dans un refuge d'urgence, en
couchsurfing ou en séjournant chez un ami,
vous aurez votre propre maison, la
réponse ne peut pas être que nous allons construire des
abris d'urgence de plus en plus grands, cela signifie que
nous devons réformer le système et
l'améliorer.  connecter les gens aux services
qui vont les sortir
de l'itinérance
[Musique]
venez ici chercher quelque chose à manger ou à boire
ou des chaussettes propres et sèches pour
y accéder, je pense que c'est dans un bon emplacement avec un
accès 24 heures sur 24 Adama WTTW yatra yusuf
al  -aziz même Pisco pareil, n'est-ce pas Jeff ou
Tottenham
[Musique]
toi